Jenica is with us in Appleton Wisconsin
hi Jenica how are you are you better
than I deserve what's up okay well
thanks taking my cards great to actually
talk to you I am in baby steps negative
zero I am in a big hole of debt from
some situations that have happened the
last couple of years
currently I just recently quit my
full-time job and got two part-time jobs
because I couldn't afford the daycare
for my son I don't know if that was the
right move but into where I'm at right
now
I'm bringing in about twenty two hundred
a month and I'm getting a refund back
for my taxes and I'm wondering what to
do with it exactly I'm getting about
sixty six hundred dollars and I'm
wondering whether to pay off my debt or
to pay ahead on my rent because right
now I barely make it month-to-month and
you said you're how old
twenty-four twenty-four and you have one
childhood two-and-a-half-year-old yeah
how much child support do you receive
two fifty I'll come solo no idea that's
the thing about okay and I have my I am
I spent about ninety percent of the time
so I don't really you know they're all I
get a break to work much more than I
already do which you know I've tried the
whole you say you know did your income
bigger but I just don't really have that
option anymore yeah where's your family
they're all in Lhasa which is about two
hours from my home I don't know what why
are you where you are
I initially moved here for the job that
I just quit but then the housing and
daycare kind of bit me in the butt with
how expensive it was versus what I was
making I was making about 34,000 a years
but
what were you doing before I was a
receptionist at a VA clinic okay yeah
and you moved to Appleton to take that
job kind of kind of not i wasa don't
really have anything for jobs or for
anything really so i moved here for that
reason i need to be closer to my son's
dad and I do have a sibling that lives
closer to me here but yeah that's the
only family that's close by how's your
relationship with your parents great but
I'm actually in 10,000 dollars of debt
to them because they've helped me too
much and I tell them no longer can help
me because I cannot afford to pay them
back yeah understand okay so what we've
got to do is to fix your income short
term and long term obviously the
part-time job of some kind you're doing
two now but your income still sucks so
we've got to do something to get your
income up short-term doing anything
that's legal and moral then long-term
we've got to have a career path which
you haven't mentioned one right well my
biggest thing my where I was at the VA
is kind of where I wanted to be
long-term I like the receptionist I
parole and I was making good money there
but the biggest reason I quit there and
got my two part-time jobs is because at
my two part-time jobs I can bring my son
with so that eliminates my daycare
completely which was eight twenty a
month yeah so you're netting more that
way yeah right it's logical on the
short-term it doesn't get you to your
long-term goals but long-term your goal
should be more than receptionist at the
VA I'm talking about when you're 36
years old 12 years from now what are you
going to be doing with your life that
makes you $90,000 a year I have no idea
that's what we need to work on that's
what we need to be thinking about and
working through that process and then
take some steps that help you get there
you can tolerate a lot of pain and
inconvenience on the short-term
if it's good for you and your son on the
long-term agreed right and so if you
made a little less or were
inconvenienced a lot more or both or
made more and work inconvenienced a lot
more and you cleaned up your debts and
you start to build some a little bit of
a savings account where you can actually
go to school and be a dot dot dot
whatever it is you want to be and I want
to go into this field I want to be going
to that field where I can make some
serious change and have a high quality
life going forward for me and my child
but the problem is if you aim at nothing
you're gonna hit it every time nothing
and so we have to have a better plan for
your life going forward that has more
vision to it than you've got right now
the reason I was asking about home and
your parents was on the short-term like
for a year if you could work a hundred
hours a week doing something and your
mom watched your son for free you could
clean up a lot but you'd be working all
the time but I'm talking about for one
year you can do anything for one year if
you're going somewhere with it but that
would be to get mom and dad paid off to
get the any other debts paid off and put
some money in the bank so you can go
take a class on whatever it is you want
to be when you're 36 okay but I think
you've got a little bit of dreaming to
do you've been just desperate about
eating right and I want to get your I
want to get your eyes off of Friday on
to Friday when you're 36 and start to go
okay what are the what's that gonna look
like
let's get that dream down out of the
clouds and let's get it into HD so we
can see all the clarity of it and then
let's think about what if that's my
desired future if it's where I'm going
then I have to ask myself what has to be
true okay I want to be I want to be an
RN okay the nursing schools in your
future or I want to be a welder okay
then you've got to go get a
certification from the Tech College on
that or I want to be a Ruby on Rails
developer then good you need to get them
around some guys and gals that do coding
and you know learn learn the [ __ ]
pewter world or I don't care what you
want to do as long as you go about doing
it but what you're doing right now you
don't want to be doing when you're 36
are we in agreement on that yeah okay
all right so step back a step or two and
then that will tell you a little better
what to do with this $6,600 no I would
not prepay your rent
I would put it aside as an emergency
fund and or to pay for the class you're
gonna go take or classes are going to go
take or to pay for your move back home
so mom can watch your baby for a little
while if mom is willing to do that for a
short period of time and this is not mom
I want you to raise the child for me for
the next ten years this is for one year
because I'm gonna go wide open during
that year and here's what I'm going to
accomplish this this this and this and I
think I can make this kind of money and
I'll have to drive aways because there
might not be enough jobs right here
close but whatever and you start laying
out a plan that doesn't include partying
and it doesn't include worrying about
your the husband your child's father's
convenience because all he's putting in
the pots to it and $50.00 so whatever
convenience he needs to have to see his
son or child it needs to be his little
butts in his little car driving up to
see them because you got to go make a
life for yourself you're stuck right now
your poverty looking for a place to
happen if you don't change this
direction and that's what I want you to
look at now I want you to think through
this you can do this
we'll help you I'll walk you through the
process I'm going to send you a copy of
Chris Christie Wright's book business
boutique as it might be a small business
idea bumping around in your head that
you want to go try I don't care what it
is I just want you to dream again and I
want you to dream past survival past
Friday and then you can start taking the
steps to get there it's worth
sacrificing to build a better life for
yourself and your child and but you got
to have a path you got to have a map a
step-by-step game plan on what it's
going to take to get there and you can
do that